a mobster ratting on his lifelong
accomplices an ironic cover song in an
anonymous suburb and a farewell barrage
of gunshots from a ghost if the final
chapter of henry hill's story left you
with some questions we've got you
covered this is the ending of goodfellas
finally explained
in the world of the mafia nothing is
worse than being a rat in other words
there's no bigger taboo than becoming a
witness for the authorities aiming to
take down organized crime syndicates so
some viewers may wonder why ray liotta's
henry hill turns on his adopted
felonious family at the end of
goodfellas essentially hill turned rat
to survive after three decades of
working with the mob henry is cut off
when he gets arrested for trafficking
cocaine a criminal trade specifically
forbidden by mob boss paul cicero after
his arrest and subsequent ousting his
longtime partner in crime and supposed
friend jimmy the gent conway attempts to
have henry and his wife karen whacked
out of money and friends henry turns to
the only organization that will have him
the federal bureau of investigation his
sworn testimony puts both jimmy and paul
behind bars and serves as scorsese's
final word on the titular goodfellas in
the end henry's testimony isn't proof
that crime doesn't pay the movie shows
just how well it can it's proof that
living without any morals only ends in
pain isolation or prison henry's choices
backed him into a corner and scorsese
makes sure the audience knows henry had
to chew his way out like a rat to see
another day
some viewers may be confused by the shot
of joe pesci's tommy devito firing
directly into frame in the closing
monologue devito is dead murdered for
his unsanctioned whacking of made man
billy batson because the image is
seemingly unrelated to hill's final
address to the audience however the
image is there for a reason in an
interview with afi scorsese explains the
shot is a homage to 1903's the great
train robbery the movie about a gang who
holds up a steam engine is famous for
being one of the first narrative films
like goodfellas the silent film ends
with a shot of one of the gang firing a
revolver directly into the screen
scorsese tells afi he included the shot
because goodfellas and the great train
robbery are both representative of
popular culture's fascination with
outlaws he also notes the film's plots
are virtually the same both movies
follow groups of outlaws who get away
with big scores before killing each
other or being apprehended by the law
all this history means devito firing
into frame is no random stylistic
flourish instead scorsese uses the shot
to connect goodfellas to the long film
tradition of rooting for the bad guys
until the law comes crashing down on
their heads
in an interview with film comments
scorsese said he didn't believe the
mafiosos and goodfellas thought about
their actions to capture this on screen
he tried to make them as primitive as
possible just straight ahead want take
simple during the opening scene henry's
narration begins with the line
as far back as i can remember i always
wanted to be a gangster following this
line tony bennett's rags to riches roars
over the movie's titles in the final
scene of the film before title cards and
credits roll henry ends his narration
saying on average nobody
get to live the rest of my life like a
schnook he then enters the home the fbi
placed him in and closes its door on the
viewers the parallels between the
narrations open and its close mirror the
audience's journey with henry at the
beginning audiences are thrust into the
car with henry as he drives down the
road to being a gangster at the end
henry leaves the audience outside his
new life in home he was a gangster now
he is a schnook the ride's over and
henry is out of the life he loved
goodfellas has one of the all-time
greatest movie soundtracks scorsese's
song choices underscore mood and time
period throughout the film it also helps
that scorsese's ear for music seems to
be as strong as his eye for shots for
example in goodfellas he pairs the
melancholic second half of derek and the
domino's layla with a murder montage
it's a stroke of genius however the
majority of the film's song choices are
radio hits from their respective decades
so some viewers may wonder why sid
vicious cover of frank sinatra's my way
closes out the film it's from the decade
when the film ends but its punk edge
breaks away from the sounds of the
movie's pop and rock motif scorsese said
he felt the reason he chose the song
seemed pretty obvious given the song's
ironic take on the original's meaning
the characters and goodfellas certainly
lived life their way but unlike
sinatra's original recording the
mobster's unique approach to life did
not bring them to triumphant heights
instead their actions left them
imprisoned murdered by their peers or
rotting anonymously in a suburb
throughout the film henry brags about
the lack of responsibility afforded to
gangsters they don't pay taxes endure
commutes or believe in good government
bullsh but this comes with a heavy price
and vicious my way underscores its cost
brilliantly
goodfellas is based on the life and
times of real mob associate henry hill
whose story was recorded in nicholas
palegi's book wiseguy scorsese tweaked
some of henry's story when bringing it
to the big screen for example the movie
never identifies which specific crime
family hill and his friends were
associated with in reality henry jimmy
and tommy worked with the lucasy crime
family under coppo regime paul vario
vario is portrayed as paul cicero in the
film and he's not the only character to
receive a name change tommy devito was
modeled after tommy desimone jimmy
conway was based on james burke in an
interview with the tampa bay times
following henry hill's death henry's
sister lucille claimed james burke was
much worse in real life the movie also
cut some real life events for example in
his memoir gangsters and goodfellas
henry claims his wife slept with boss
paul vario while henry was in jail also
the movie does not include james burke's
role in a boston college basketball
point shaving scandal given the finite
run time of a film and the laundry list
of misdeeds committed by the characters
it's based on it's no wonder scorsese
shaved away some details to fit his
vision into one movie
goodfellas changed how gangsters and
criminals were depicted in american
entertainment and is considered one of
the best mob movies of all time in his
1990 review famed critic roger ebert
said no finer film has ever been made
about organized crime not even the
godfather however burrowing into the
popular culture consciousness of movie
fans everywhere is not the movie's only
major achievement it's also been cited
as a source of inspiration for arguably
the greatest show of all time the
sopranos in an interview with peter
bogdanovich soprano's creator david
chase said the movie was a major
inspiration for his show he specifically
cited the humor that arose during scenes
when the hardened criminals were simply
hanging out the odd blend of absurdism
and violence in goodfellas that color
scenes like spiders shooting or the late
night dinner with tommy's mom can be
felt in virtually every episode of the
sopranos hey tommy if i'm gonna break
your ball that day to go home and get
your shine box
[Laughter]
while making a movie that's been called
perfect by critics is no small feat it's
even more impressive to inspire the show
that kicked off the prestige tv moment
because of its impact goodfellas won't
be sleeping with the fishes anytime soon
for fans everywhere firing up another
re-watch of goodfellas is as good as
vinnie's tomato sauce check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you